[Music]
in spoiled brat news
my kids are spoiling I think okay no
only you think I I'm not sure because
I'm comparing my life
okay y'all do totally knows but mine I
know I wasn't spoiled because we're too
poor to be spoiled right so we're happy
for everything poor people can be spoke
to you what yeah you could spoil them by
never disciplining them or by going into
debt for them oh I never thought about
that that's what my parents my parents
with the debt for you oh yeah
why did you let them do that Christmas
you can't afford it yeah they were like
hooking it up at Christmas and then I
found out later that like Oh critic or
did oh my god I know it's why are you
only child
no no I'm one of four that's a lot of
Legos yeah and we need the new Legos I
can't just have the same language just
[ __ ] use the same Legos and create
the new set come on man I know I guess
it doesn't look exactly like the
Millennium Falcon's yes see that's the
whole that's what saved Lego mm-hmm
licensing things they're like man nobody
cares about these but Star Wars we're
back in the game kids that's why I
Lincoln is like they got a daycare
pocket on lock people they're like too
long you say like have you broken Legos
if you like Legos they get lost yeah I
don't know laughs can you imagine the
link another like you can make different
cabins a little kid in a [ __ ] flannel
just Lynch
no vision with Lincoln Logs I got a
partner with old presidents or something
get the business up submitted by Kim
Jong Un's
mistress Oh whose keep North Korea yeah
who's Kim Jung kill his dad oh that song
was there there grandpa
or his Bruce Graham is the great Craig
so does he even get voted in or they
just pass it to me looks like a hundred
percent vote voted in wasn't voted in I
don't know if we call it he might have
said it was voted in for me they might
even have an election to well like in
Russia right he even had a president but
he was like in charge all of us so lucky
really yeah this guy Medvedev he yeah
like he was just a figure out it was
like his right hand and then he became a
president and then they switched again
oh snap
that's a nice job you'll take that
that's not fair a young man scratched a
brand new BMW at the dealership so his
dad would have to buy it for him okay my
kid I'm just getting hot right now
finger my kids trying something like
that like you would for sure beat the
[ __ ] out of him after but that was
really smart
okay would you would you just be like
that's not even that's not smart that
you're just a [ __ ] [ __ ] now no but
that's like understanding loopholes to
get away why that's pretty [ __ ] smart
to go dad I guess you have to buy it
okay but you're thinking like a kid
right wait you're thinking like a child
like at all oh my god someone that's
driving it at 15 oh no fella kid nah
yeah cuz if someone was in their 20s
doing this that's like your pathetic
fool
see how Bart tried to make it work
though
hey that's what creeps me out about your
mind why you tried to make this water
make everything when I know it's scary
to make everything I'll be so mad at my
kid oh I wouldn't know yeah cuz 15 is
like I want it so bad how am I gonna get
it and he was like clever enough to do
it cuz he can't work for it it took
place in China so it's a 22 year old
Chinese child Chinese child who is very
very spoiled that's like a $300,000 BMW
then because it's a very dent exported
teacher
it's like 200% 300% times 3 mod agent
countries have crazy luxury taxes I
doesn't Denmark tutors oh [ __ ] I wasn't
Denmark talking to a Dane Dane he was
like I was like dude you got a car
that's crazy he's like [ __ ] I paid for
two cars to get a car you think I don't
really want to have a car yeah we do
people are like yeah you pay that much
for a car right so there were some that
there was surveillance footage that was
taken from inside the BMW showroom that
showed this man was like swiping the
card or with a key oh so he did he went
ham on it so this is what scene and then
there was someone there but they don't
really mention who this is because
reports are saying that he was in the
showroom he was looking at cars and he
got excited when he finally picked one
he called up his dad and apparently his
dad said something on the phone that
upset him so he ended up doing this to
the car and immediately that's when the
salespeople were like what the [ __ ] like
they called the cops and then this guy
was like oh don't trip don't trip my
dad's gonna pay for it my daddy gonna
pay it like the break it you buy it all
the policy whatever is what he thought
you could use as a loop
I licked it is man he would over its
bank
it's my solid scratches yeah that was
like an upset girlfriend curse but if he
was trying to do that and go I need a
discount this is damaged no you give a
deal backfired because the cops still
showed up he was detained good don't
worry man it's okay
he goes no it's not okay maybe if your
dad buys that's that was still a crime
well we don't know that for sure what if
the dad is that totally it was like hey
man it's too expensive I got the right
idea make it cheaper
well yeah but how [ __ ] spoiled my kid
was born there not that yeah what so
what about your kids oh come and tell
you Bart
I was I was inevitable though oh yeah
because like every what yeah yeah that
aside because like all of her kids are
gonna have a better life than you
anyways and I want my kids to appreciate
how hard my life was yeah yeah you need
to understand yeah so I picked over from
school one day and I'm like you know you
guys want to grab a snack before you go
home or you what do you wanna eat and
I'm thinking Wendy's McDonald's that
she's a party they said Benihana I wanna
spend $6 total on both of you what makes
you think I wanna yes let's all sit down
order you want a shrimp flew into your
mouth the choo-choo train all that after
school on a Tuesday are you crazy
so how did you do this to your children
Benihana with their birthday and stuff
but Tuesday's also like we don't is
enough for you to request it yeah
restaurant that's like oh my god
Benihana right not like Benihana is fine
I guess you guys so we win
it's fun though
Benihana is great living life
spontaneous and that's the first world
problem when I go to Benihana and just
not impressed
haven't seen a new trick in 20 tricks
are the same yeah my go heart beat cool
it's mainly just the salt shaker and
they just go like this
they're doing a lot but now it's just
spinning they're not only doing that
much I learned how to do this first show
I was doing and it was way harder than I
thought
just trying to like flip the spatula and
stuff the grills hot house maybe the
show left with Steve Aoki's dad he
started yep my brain shut off and then
rebooted well yeah so the I think his
name is rocky something
yeah rocky ioki what does that really
see VIPs dad yeah that is a huge like
sumo wrestler restaurateur kind of guy
wait no he wasn't a sumo wrestler
Tsugumi guy that's dude no yeah yeah he
he was a real estate and restaurant guy
and he came up and then Benihana back in
the day used to be like a straight up
show like Vegas in different cities like
really yeah it's supposed to be like you
dressed [ __ ] nice and you go in and
like this like like the local celebs are
there and and it's like a cool spot and
then I heard the performances were
better and all that [ __ ] to what it used
to be like a high-end place like [ __ ]
mint Drake said it wasn't cool in a song
like we offer Benihana but he also said
I like Cheesecake Factory yeah yeah
[Music]
experience well it was my fault I'm not
good at math I took my friend he was
Doughboy the separating his first year
of sobriety so we're at Nobu like I'm
about to treat you my brother I love you
congratulations so the Wagyu beef is per
ounce and I didn't do the math right on
more4 ounce minimum yeah so I'm like oh
yeah bring that up I was like it's like
40 bucks something like that
my kids were there that's 40 bucks
accounts yeah but it's a 4-ounce minute
yeah I didn't get that part so every
time I thought they're bringing me one
ounce this was like four eight right so
we're like oh we're loving the walk you
bring another round i watch these guys
man we saw we have three rounds of Wagyu
when I saw that bill I was like I'm
gonna that's like 700 bucks oh it was
more than that that's your kids new
snack like four rounds of Wagyu up gonna
get four rounds of Wagyu down it is me
I'm the one in the scooby-doo mascot
take the master it's me it's me dude I'm
in the know blue and I'm a 35 year old
man no you're taking [ __ ] kids to
Nobu they don't have a chance at joy in
life hey guys starting out Wendy's when
I was a kid going out to dinner like
like was nuts and when you we went to
[ __ ] chi Chi's which is a Mexican
chain restaurants McDonald's it was like
Benihana yeah yeah get a whole happy
place it was like a big place I get my
own tray yeah I get to organize my fries
and might catch it the way I want to do
you or you catch up on the [ __ ] laces
Bart lays his [ __ ] french fries on
plastic and then slowly surgically
dissect them he does it with the fork
and a knife
he makes the work
[Music]